[Music]  what I would say to myself starting out  is that this does actually happen hard  work it does actually  or you might think just continue writing  continue drawing continue dots and  continue trying to make stuff make sure  your North Star is what in your heart  and what you uniquely have to offer an  audience but I would tell my younger  self don't go to business school because  you're gonna decide later if you love  filmmaking you're gonna go all in that  way just follow your instincts  you probably may be right don't be  afraid to learn from other people and  ask a lot of questions you know and  sometimes keep following your inner  voice keep being stubborn and hold down  to your curiosity like your life depends  on  [Music]